[موسيقى]
سياسه امنيه جديده لواشنطن في الشرق
الاوسط وبريطانيا لا تملك ما يكفي من
الذخيره سوى لاسبوع واحد فقط هذه الملفات
وغيرها نطرحها معكم في حلقه اليوم اهلا
بكم في عسك
ري الجيش الامريكي يبحث عن تزويد ترسانته
بالصواريخ متوسطه المدى بعد انسحاب واشنطن
من معاهده الصواريخ قصيره ومتوسطه المدى
مع روسيا يتنافس في تصنيع هذا الصاروخ
شركه لوكيد مارتن الامريكيه وكذلك شركه
انورثروب روما وريثيوم الصاروخ الجديد
ستستخدمه الولايات المتحده في مناطق
المحيطين الهندي والهدئ وكذلك سيكون صاروخ
فائق ادقه وقد اطلق عليه اسم ال ار ام
الجيش الالماني يعزز قدرته بمئه مركبه
مدرعه استراليه من طراز بوكسر مجهزه بمدفع
من عيار 30 مليمتر المدرعات الجديده ستحل
محل مدرعات ويزل 2 والتي يستخدمها الجيش
الالماني من المقرر ان تتسلم برلين هذه
المركبات بحلول عام 2025 وبينما لم تكشف
عن قيمه هذه الصفقه اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الالمانيه انه سيتم تمويلها من الصندوق
الذي تم تخصيصه لتحديث الجيش الالماني بعد
الحرب في اوكرانيا والذي تصل قيمته الى
100 مليار
[موسيقى]
كوريا الجنوبيه اعلنت البدء في تطوير
مسيرات عموديه لنشرها على متن مدمرات
الجويه الجديده ستتمتع بقدرات استطلاع
متقدمه بالاضافه الى مستشعرات كهرو بصريه
وكذلك اخرى تعمل بالاشعه تحت الحمراء هذا
لضمان قدرتها على العمل ليلا ونهارا وكذلك
في ظروف الطقس المختلفه حيث ستستخدم هذه
المسيرات في البحر الاصفر بالقرب من الجزر
المتنازع عليها بين الكوريتين البرنامج
الجديد سيتكلف 421 مليون دولار ومن
المنتظر ان تدخل اولى هذه المسيرات الى
الخدمه بحلول عام 2031
احدث تنامي الدوره الصيني في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط ازمه للقياده الامريكيه في كيفيه
التعامل مع هذه التطورات التي تؤثر على
مكانه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
المنطقه في وقت تتحدث فيه تقارير عن تحول
اهتمام واشنطن لكبح جماح النفوذ الصيني في
اسيا وكذلك التعامل مع التطورات الحرب في
اوكرانيا كل هذه الامور يعتقد البعض انها
تاتي على حساب منطقه مثل منطقه الشرق
الاوسط للوقوف اكثر على الاستراتيجيه
الامنيه الجديده لوشنطن في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط في المرحله الحاليه وخاصه في ظل
التغيرات الاستراتيجيه الاخيره انضموا
الينا السفير روبرت فورد سفير الولايات
المتحده سابقا لدى سوريا وايضا لدى
الجزائر اولا روبرت اهلا بك معنا في
عسكريتانيا تحدثت عن استراتيجيه امنيه
جديده لواشنطن في هذه المرحله اولا هل لك
ان تطلعنا على ابرز معالم هذه
الاستراتيجيه وكذلك كيف تقيمها
المقاربه الامريكيه الجديده للامن في
الخليج تكمن في اشراك عدد اكبر من دول
المنطقه في هذه العمليه الدفاعيه فمثلا
هناك تركيز امريكي جديد على اشراك القوات
المسلحه السعوديه والاماراتيه والبحرينيه
والكويتيه ودول اخرى من الشرق الاوسط مثل
الاردن ومصر وحتى اسرائيل وهذه المقاربه
التي تركز على دول المنطقه تختلف تماما عن
مقاربتنا قبل 20 عاما والمقاربه الامريكيه
الجديده تركز على مجالين بشكل اساسي الاول
هو الدفاع الجوي الاقليمي والثاني هو
الدفاع البحري الاقليمي
لكن التغيرات الاستراتيجيه الاخيره التي
تشهدها هذه المنطقه هل اثرت على هذا
الهيكل الامني الاقليميه التي سعت
الولايات المتحده لسنوات الى بنائه في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط
المقاربه الجديده غيرت قليلا من اسلوب نشر
القوات الامريكيه ولكن يجب ان اوضح
للمشاهدين ان امريكا لا تزال قلقه بشكل
حقيقي من تهديد ايران تجاه شركاء امريكا
في منطقه الخليج وهذا التهديد الايراني من
وجهه نظر واشنطن لم يتلاشى ولا يزال يمثل
مشكله كبيره وامريكا بدات تدمج وبشكل
متزايد القوات العسكريه الاقليميه مع
الوحدات العسكريه الامريكيه والهدف هو
تحقيق دفاع اقوى في المنطقه كما تمكنت
امريكا من تقليص قواتها قليلا لتستبدلها
بقوات شركائنا مثل المملكه العربيه
السعوديه او الامارات العربيه المتحده او
دول اخرى الا ان اهتمام امريكا بامن
الخليج لم يتغير
[موسيقى]
روبرت الصين رعت مؤخرا اتفاقا بين
السعوديه وايران لكن برايك كيف سينعكس هذا
الاتفاق على العلاقه الامنيه ما بين
الولايات المتحده ومنطقه الخليج
بشكل عام هو لا يغير الالتزام الامريكيه
لمساعده دول الخليج في الدفاع عن نفسها
ولا يغير عمل امريكا في التدريبات
العسكريه المشتركه مع جيوش المنطقه في
الدفاع البحري ولكن هناك تخوف في واشنطن
من ان الصين اذا ما قامت ببناء منشات في
الخليج فهذه المنشات الصينيه قد تؤثر على
امن القوات الامريكيه فالامريكيون قلقون
جدا من علم الاستخبارات الصينيه
بالمعلومات حول القدرات العسكريه المتقدمه
التي نزودها للمملكه العربيه السعوديه او
الى الامارات العربيه المتحده وقبل عامين
عبرت امريكا عن قلقها لابو ظبي حول منشاه
عسكريه صينيه كانت ستتمكن من الحصول على
معلومات استخباراتيه حول طائره امريكيه
متقدمه كانت تفكر في بيعها للامارات
العربيه المتحده
سفير روبرت يعني هناك من يقول بانه
الولايات المتحده اهمال واشنطن للمخاوف
الامنيه لدول هذه المنطقه هو ما دفع او ما
عزز وساعه وساهم في تنامي النفوذ الصني في
هذه المرحله هل تتفق مع هذه الرؤيه
هناك قلق من شركائنا بين دول الخليج حول
التزام امريكا خاصه بعد الهجوم على بقيق
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه عام 2019
وهذا القلق الخليجي مفهوم بشكل كامل
ولكنني اعتقد اننا يجب ان ندرك ان اداره
بايدن تختلف عن اداره ترامب حيث تتبع
اداره بيض المقاربه تقليديه في السياسه
الخارجيه الامريكيه وبخلاف اداره ترامب
فان اداره بايدن تو الاهتماما بالغا
للاقتصاد الدولي وبالتالي طول اهتماما
خاصا باسواق الطاقه كما لم تفعل اداره
ترامب ابدا
هل صحيح انك ارسلت رساله للكونجرس
الامريكيه تطالب فيها بسحب كافه القوات
الامريكيه من الاراضي السوريه ولماذا ان
صحت هذه المعلومات
لقد بعثت تلك الرساله بالفعل هذا صحيح
فمنذ عام 2018 وهزيمه داعش في سوريا طالبت
بانسحاب القوات الامريكيه من شرق سوريا
والسبب هو لان القوات الامريكيه في شرق
سوريا لا تستطيع القضاء بشكل كامل على
داعش فقط السوريون وبشكل خاص السنه في شرق
سوريا هم القادرون على القضاء على داعش
بالكامل ازاله المحفزات للانضمام الى داعش
ليست بالمهمه التي يستطيع 900 جندي امريكي
القيام بها هذا الامر بيد السوريين واذا
ما تمكنت اميركا من تقديم المساعده مثلا
في عمليات اعاده البناء او تقديم
المساعدات لتحقيق الاستقرار فهذه مسائل
نستطيع دراستها اما 900 جندي فلا يستطيعون
القضاء بشكل كامل على داع ش
كان
صفير روبرت فورد سفير الولايات المتحده
السابقا لدى سوريا وكذلك لدى الجزائر شكرا
جزيلا على وجودك معنا
بينما تستمر التدريبات العسكريه بين كوريا
الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده يشرف زعيم
كوريا الشماليه على تجارب لصواريخ صواريخ
لديها قدره على حمل رؤوس نوويه اخر هذه
التجارب كان اطلاق صاروخ عابر للقارات
يسمى وسونغ 17 هو صوم سبعه عشر هو صاروخ
عابر للقارات يطلق من منصه متحركه على
اليه كبيره تم انتاجها محليا هذا يعني ان
كوريا الشماليه باتت تستطيع تصنيع ما تريد
من هذا الصاروخ في ارجاء البلد هو صمت 17
هو صاروخ مكون من مرحلتين وكذلك يستخدم
الوقود السائل مما يعني انه يجب تزويده
بالوقود قبل الاطلاق مباشره وليس قبل
النقل مما يزيد من فتره تحضيره للاستخدام
يعتقد المراقبون ان هو 17 يستطيع حمل عده
رؤوس حربيه مما يصعب عمليه اعتراضها ويزيد
كذلك من قوتها التدميريه يعتقد الخبراء ان
اول تجربه لهذا الصاروخ كانت في اكتوبر من
عام 2020 والتي صادفت الذكرى الخامسه
والسبعين لتاسيس حزب العمال الحاكم برئاسه
كيم جونغ اون خلال عام 2022 تم اجراء
تجربتين لنفس الصاروخ وصل في اخرها الى
ارتفاع اقنع المسؤولين في الولايات
المتحده وكذلك في اليابان بانه بالفعل
صاروخ عابر للقارات ويمكن ان يصل مداه حتى
15 الف كيلو متر هذا الامر سيضع اي هدف في
الولايات المتحده في مرمى نيران فيونغ
مؤخرا اجرت كوريا الشماليه تجربه اخرى
لنفس الصاروخ وصل خلالها الى ارتفاع تجاوز
سته الاف كيلو متر وطار لمسافه تصل الى
الف كيلو متر لاكثر من 69 دقيقه قبل ان
يسقط في عرض البحر
[موسيقى]
بعد الفاصل بريطانيا تحتاج لعشر سنوات
لتعويض المساعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد منذ بدايه الحرب في
اوكرانيا قدمت دول حلف شمال الاطلسي الاف
الاطنان من الاسلحه والذخائر لدعم
اوكرانيا في الحرب
كانت وما زال بريطانيا من الدول التي
اسهمت بشكل كبير في دعم اوكرانيا منذ
بدايه الحرب لكن هذا الامر جاء على حساب
امنها حسب بعض المسؤولين البريطانيين
الذين حضروا مؤخرا من تدني مخزون القوات
المسلحه البريطانيه من الاسلحه وان
المملكه المتحده في حال واجهت اي حرب ليس
لديها من الذخيره ما يكفي سوى لاسبوع واحد
فقط لمناقشه خطط بريطانيا لبناء قوتها
العسكريه وكذلك كيف انعكست الحرب في
اوكرانيا على مخزون المملكه المتحده من
الاسلحه معنا السيد بيتر فلا السيد مستشار
شؤون الدفاع لمجله الدفاع والامن الاوروبي
اولا مستر بيتر اهلا بك معنا في
عسكريتاريا يعني الكثير من الحكومات
تعاقبت منذ بدايه الحرب في اوكرانيا لكن
موقف الحكومات هذه لم يتغير في المملكه
المتحده بل احيانا يتخذ منح اكثر تشددا
لماذا وكيف تفسر اسباب هذا الموقف المتشدد
من الحكومه البريطانيه روسيا منذ بدايه
الحرب
هناك ادراك في بريطانيا انه اذا ما استمرت
روسيا من دون مقاومه واذا لم نقدم الدعم
لاوكرانيا فالمساله بالتالي لن تتوقف في
اوكرانيا والدول التاليه ستكون هي دول
البلطيق لذلك علينا ان نتخذ موقفا قويا
لدعم الحكومه الديمقراطيه في اوكرانيا
مستر بيتر لجنه الدفاع بالبرلمان
البريطانيه حضرت من انه مخزون المملكه
المتحده من الاسلحه بسبب دعم اوكرانيا في
الحرب لم يعد يكفي سوى لاسبوع واحد فقط في
حال نشوب اي نزاع مسلح تورطت فيه بريطانيا
هل تعتقد بان هذه المعلومات صحيحه وما هو
السبيل لحل هذه المشكله
انا متاكد من ان هذا الكلام صحيح لان هناك
عددا قليلا من الدول التي تحافظ على
مستويات عاليه من العسكري والذخائر كما ان
مخزون الذخائر يبقى من دون استخدام في
الدوله التي لا تخوض صراعا عسكريا ولا
توفر ذخيره الى دوله داخله في صراع عسكري
وعندما تنفذ مده صلاحيه الذخائر علينا
التخلص منها وهذه العمليه تكلف اموالا
طائله لذلك نادرا ما نجد دوله تحافظ على
مساواه عاليه من الذخيره وبعد اندلاع
الصراع في اوكرانيا وجدت عده دول نفسها في
الموقف نفسه وليس فقط بريطانيا بل امريكا
ايضا التي تعيش نفس الظروف فيما يخص
مخزونها العسكري خاصه الصواريخ وهناك
خطوات في امريكا وبريطانيا حاليا لتعزيز
سلاسل الامداد التي توفر هذه الاسلحه
لاننا لا نتحدث عن شركات واحده فقط بل
مقاول رئيسي واحد وعده شركات تزود
المكونات وقد بدات الحكومات الان في
مراجعه سلاسل الامداد لتعمل على تقويتها
كيف تقيم خطه الحكومه البريطانيه لتح
القوات المسلحه خاصه في ظل ازمه اقتصاديه
تنعكس على الموازنه العامه بشكل عام وعلى
الميزانيه الدفاعيه بشكل خاص
هذه المساله معقده نوعا ما على الرغم من
الزياده المعلنه في ميزانيه الدفاع
البريطانيه وهذا ما طلب به وزراء الدفاع
بشكل متعاقب حيث ان طموحات الحكومه
البريطانيه الخاصه بقواتها المسلحه فقط
دائما الموارد التي توفرها لها ما نواجهه
في البيئه الحاليه هو ان تضخم اثر على
مفعول الزياده في الميزانيه وكانه لم تكن
هناك زياده وهذه المشكله تفاقمت بعد
تبرعنا بالمعدات الاوكرانيا
مستر بيتر الولايات المتحده نفد بشكل قاطع
ارسال اي مقاتلات امريكيه الصنع الى
اوكرانيا في هذه المرحله على الاقل لكن
بريطانيا والحكومه البريطانيه ت هذا الباب
مفتوح هل تعتقد بانه لندن من الممكن ان
تغامر بمثل هذه الخطوه
شخصيا لا اعتقد ان هذه الخطوه عمليه لان
الطائرات المقاتله الوحيده التي تمتلكها
القوات الجويه البريطانيه هي اليوروفايتر
تايفون وطائرات المقاتله المشتركه
لوك هيد مارتن ومن المستبعد جدا ان توافق
الولايات المتحده على نقل الطائرات
المقاتله المشتركه الى اوكرانيا لانها
طائرات حديثه جدا من الجيل الخامس وتحمل
تكنولوجيا لا نرغب ان تقع بايدي الروس اذا
ما قاموا باسقاطها مثلا وطائرات تايفون
الوحيده التي يمكن ان نزودهم بها هي تشانش
واحد وهي الطراز الاقدم الذي سيسحب قريبا
من الخدمه العسكريه في بريطانيا ولا اعتقد
انها قوه ناجعه لانها صعبه الصيانه
والاوكرانيون بحاجه للتدريب من اجل التمكن
من قيادتها والمحافظه عليها كما ان كل هذا
العمل سيكون صعبا جدا داخل اوكرانيا ولذلك
اعتقد ان الامر المنطقي في هذه الحاله هو
ان نتبع ما قامت به بولندا وسلوفاكيا من
خلال تزويد اوكرانيا بطائرات ميك 29 وهي
نفس الطائرات التي تستخدمها اوكرانيا
ويعرفون كيفيه قيادتها والمحافظه عليها
وستستخدم في المعارك بشكل فعال من دون
عمليات الصيانه المكثفه والتدريب وكل
الامور الاخرى التي ستكون مكلفه ماديا
وزمنيا
الاوروبي شكرا جزيلا على ما تفضلت به من
توضيحات
[موسيقى]
طائره امريكيه حققت انتصارات اكثر من اي
طائره اخرى صنعتها الولايات المتحده في
فتره الحرب العالميه الثانيه استخدمت في
عمليات الهجوم البريه وحققت هيمنه جويه
كبيره في معارك الجو جو المقاتله الهجوميه
اي الصاعقه باللغه العربيه
حلقت مقاتله للمره الاولى في العام 1941
كما خضعت العدد من التعديلات جعلتها اكبر
واثقل مقاتله بمحرك واحد خلال الحرب
العالميه الثانيه
زودت هذه المقاتله بثمانيه مدافع رشاشه
كما كان لديها قدره على حمل قنبلتين او
اكثر هذا طبعا بحسب وزن هذه القنابل على
الرغم من تعدد مهام افندمبولت الا انها
غالبا ما كانت تستخدم في توفير حمايه
للقاذفات في مهام متوسطه المدى اضافه الى
اعتبارها من اقوى المقاتلات في المواجهات
الجويه على ارتفاعات عاليه من ابرز ما
تميز به هذه المقاتله هو هيكلها القوي
الذي مكنها من مواصله مهامها حتى بعد
اصابتها خلال الاشتباكات الجويه بل
والعوده لقاعدتها بسلامه استخدمت بريطانيا
هذه المقاتله ضد اليابان في معارك جنوب
شرق اسيا كما لعبت ايضا دورا بارزا في
تدمير تحصينات الجيش اليابانيه تم انتاج
اكثر من 15 الف مقاتله من هذا التراس وظلت
في الخدمه داخل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حتى العام 1954
حلقه عسكري تاريه لهذا الاسبوع قد انتهت
الاسبوع المقبل المزيد من الاسلحه والمزيد
من الصفقات في امان الله
[موسيقى]